I've been threatened by Haiti with
Voodoo over food
I've taken mangoes from passengers from
Jamaica and been fruit my life never a
dull moment here at JFK make it easier
that's it the reason why we're
confiscating all the stuff is not
because it's harmful to the human being
it's harmful for our plants and our
animals this is a big port last month we
processed at 1.5 million passengers you
figure between fruits and vegetables
we're talking about two or three hundred
kilos a day in just one terminal so
you're talking about four to six hundred
pounds what kind of foods are you
confiscating every day is different
every season is different Chinese New
Year Christmas Easter we have beef candy
from China serrano ham from Spain we
have lots of avocados salami from Italy
no Pedro I take the back so let mr.
primo that's Spain Spain also once the
food item is seized it's put in what we
call the contraband bin we drag a
contraband being across the terminal
it's about a block form get a little
exercise and begin the process of
grinding up all the prohibited food
items we're at the grinder table that
officer will look and see if there's any
little exit holes entry holes and that's
what you're gonna find the insect do you
enjoy that part of the process is it
kind of a stress reliever for you of the
grinders great sometimes I go home with
a little bit of mango juice and passion
fruit juice on it just happened fun the
water splashing in your face but this is
what we have to do to protect American
agriculture part of our job
you